Speaker 1: Well, ladies and gentlemen,
Kerry Lake said she would win. She said
there was no way she would lose unless it was
stolen or rigged or fraudulent. She insisted,
even hours into yesterday's final counting in
Arizona, that she would ultimately prevail and
become the next governor of Arizona. And Kerry
Lake has lost. It is good news for sensible
people and sane people, not only in Arizona,
not only in the United States, but it is good
news for the world that we have a world, as Donald
Trump famously said, and that world is rejoicing.
Other than some clowns in Arizona, because Kari
Lake will not be the next governor of that state,
instead, it will be Katie Hobbs, the Democrat,
a completely uncontroversial, unremarkable, just
normal Democrat who will hopefully run Arizona in
something approximating a logical way. She won't
say, Well, we're going to secede. She won't say.
And COVID lockdowns and mandates that don't exist,
she won't try to ban abortion and on and on and
on. It has been a very slow count in Arizona,
but it was finally called yesterday. Katie Hobbs
prevailing over Carrie Lake. Carrie Lake adding
yet another major endorsement, us to Donald
Trump's list and Carrie Lake and many others
insisting that it is indeed fraud. We will look
at Carrie Lake's reaction in a moment. At the
current time, it is a nearly 20,000 vote margin
for Katie Hobbs under one point. Understand,
but it has been called and it is fortunately
very much over. What makes this all the sweeter?
And I admit I take pleasure in this. What makes
this all the sweeter is the degree of arrogant
confidence that Carrie Lake exhibited up until
quite literally hours before this was called,
the arrogant confidence of Donald Trump,
insisting that Carrie Lake would win. But
it started to flip, flip, flip and get to the
point where, well, based on the remaining votes,
Carrie Lake needs 53%. Now, of the remaining
votes, Carrie Lake needs 56%. We knew days
ago that mathematically it really just wasn't
adding up for Carrie Lake, and indeed, we have
made it. Now, what about Carrie Lake's Twitter
feed? Well, it's been relatively quiet. She has
a pinned message from September. And then only
one tweet that seems to be related to the call,
which is Arizonans know B.S. when they see it.
Arizonans no B.S. when they see it. And of course,
I had to get in there and respond to her and
tell her, indeed, Arizonans saw the voice of
your campaign and they voted for your opponent. A
repetitive screeds and tirades from Carrie Lake.
Shouldn't election officials be impartial? The
guys running the election have made it their
mission to defeat America, first Republicans.
And then if there was an issue with your ballot.
Please submit the information here. Attention.
Your vote may not have been counted. You can
check the status at Kerry Lakes slash cure.
This is a whole thing where they want to cure
the ballots. And as all of you know, why
cure with so much salt when you can cold
smoke and get all the flavor in a much less salty
ballot? I prefer cold smoking rather than curing,
but that's a culinary question for later. Kerry
like continuing, you know, your vote may not have
been counted and on and on and on. She has not
conceded as of this point in time. I could not
care less whether or not, she concedes. As many
of you know, concession is merely a formality. It
is something that, you know, reasonable
people do. Even lunatic Doug Mastriano
called Josh SHAPIRO and said, Sir, I concede,
I concede, sir, you have won this election.
Something Donald Trump never really did after
2020 and Kerry like may not do it either,
but a victory for common sense in Arizona. Let's
continue talking about this a little bit more